One thing I didn't know about delivering mail-- you're not supposed to walk down to the sidewalk after each house. You're supposed to cut across the lawn to the next house if you want to finish the route on time.
关于送邮件，我以前不知道的一件事是——你本不该在每家送信后都走回人行道上。如果你想按时完成投递路线，你应该直接穿过草坪走到下一家。
I mean, they time us. We're not supposed to go down to the sidewalk every time if we can avoid it.
我是说，他们会给我们计时。如果能避免，我们不应该每次都回到人行道上。
And just walk across people's grass.
只要直接穿过人们的草坪就行了。
Grass, yes. Everybody wants the government to be efficient, except for the mailman to walk across their grass. But people like these guys built a path for me.
草坪，没错。每个人都希望政府高效，但唯独不希望邮递员踩他们的草坪。不过像这些人一样，他们为我修建了一条小路。
So, yeah, there's a little dirt path in between these bushes.
所以，是的，这些灌木丛之间有一条泥土小径。
'Cause they're nice.
因为他们人很好。
I went out with a letter carrier named Grace as she walked around. It was a pretty day in a leafy, lovely neighborhood. Grace carried a shoulder bag with flats and catalogs and parcels. And, of course, somebody built a path for her to cut to the house next door.
我曾跟着一位名叫格蕾丝的信使在她的路线上走了一圈。那是一个绿树成荫的美丽社区，天气非常好。格蕾丝背着一个斜挎包，里面装着平信、商品目录和包裹。当然，有人为她修了一条路，让她可以抄近路去往下一家。
She can talk to anybody. She's interested in other people. So at this point, she knows at least a little bit about most of the people on her route. Most of them, she's actually seen their faces. She'll walk up to a house.
她能和任何人交谈。她对他人很感兴趣。所以走到这一步，她对路线上的大多数人都有些了解。她甚至见过其中大多数人的长相。她会走到一户人家门前。
Sometimes it'll be like the cousin out front or whatever. And I'll even know that. I'll be like, you have the same face as the wife. And I know she has family in Denmark. You're the Denmark sister. I'll just know it when I'm walking up. And then she's like, [IMITATING DANISH]. And I'm like, ah, I told you. I'll just know a lot about people.
有时可能是表亲或者什么人在门口。我甚至能看出来。我会说，你和那位妻子长得一模一样。我知道她在丹麦有亲戚。你是丹麦的那位姐妹吧。我走过去的时候自然就知道了。然后她会说（模仿丹麦语）。我就说，啊，我早就说了。关于这些人，我了解得很多。
There's the house with the stay-at-home mom whose son makes drawings for Grace, the public defenders who get public defender mail, but somehow also have an insanely posh house with gorgeous landscaping. There's the hardcore Christians whose dog always lunges at the door like he's going to break through the glass. There's the dad who organizes the kids' softball league that Grace's daughter is in and the guy with pancreatic cancer who seems like he doesn't have much time left at all.
这里住着一位全职妈妈，她的儿子给格蕾丝画画；还有公设辩护律师，他们收着公设辩护人的信件，却不知何故住着一栋极其奢华、景观优美的房子。还有狂热的基督徒，他们的狗总是扑向大门，好像要撞碎玻璃一样。还有负责组织格蕾丝女儿所在垒球队的爸爸，以及那位患有胰腺癌、看起来时日无多的男士。
And nicest guy. And it's just-- you can't help but think about it every day.
他是个大好人。你每天都忍不住会想到他。
Does he get a lot of visitors?
他有很多访客吗？
Yes, and lots of mail started coming from old friends and stuff. Yeah.
有的，很多老朋友之类的都开始寄信来了。是的。
I'm not using Grace's real name or telling you anything about where she works so this private information can stay private, like it should. Our show today is about the mail. And Grace's understanding of who's who on her route is like a pilot knowing the weather they're dealing with.
我没有使用格蕾丝的真名，也没告诉你她在哪里工作，这样这些私人信息就能像应该的那样保持隐私。我们今天的节目是关于邮件的。格蕾丝对自己路线上谁是谁的了解，就像飞行员了解他们所面对的天气一样。
It's very helpful to doing her job, like with this couple on the route where the woman moved to the apartment across the hall and filed a forwarding address, and the guy did not. But Grace knows the guy is still with her, so she forwards his mail also, even without the form. At one house this particular day, there's a postcard for the landlord who Grace knows does not live at that address.
这对于完成她的工作非常有帮助。比如路线上一对夫妇，女方搬到了走廊对面的公寓并提交了地址转发，但男方没有。格蕾丝知道男方仍和女方住在一起，所以即使没有表格，她也会帮他转发信件。这一天在某一户人家，有一张明信片是寄给房东的，格蕾丝知道房东不住在那儿。
And so what are you going to do?
那你打算怎么做？
I'm going to dispose of it in what we call the undeliverable bulk business mail bin.
我会把它扔进我们所谓的“无法投递的批量商业邮件箱”里。
UBBM. She could toss it out like that because it's not first class mail.
也就是UBBM。她可以那样处理掉它，因为它不是一等邮件。
So it doesn't get returned to sender and it doesn't get forwarded. It just goes to waste.
所以它不会被退回寄件人，也不会被转发。它就只能被浪费掉。
Oh, it's junk mail.
哦，那是垃圾邮件。
That's correct. We don't use that term.
没错。我们不用那个词。
What do you say?
你们怎么说？
We're forbidden from saying that. Bulk mail or standard class mail.
我们被禁止说那个词。是批量邮件或标准级邮件。
Because junk mail implies a value judgment.
因为垃圾邮件暗示了一种价值判断。
That's correct. And this is what pays our salaries, the so-called junk mail.
没错。正是所谓的垃圾邮件支付了我们的工资。
Grace has an ex-girlfriend on her route, somebody she was with decades ago. And earlier in the day, she tossed out a piece of bulk mail at her house. She pauses for a second before she tells me about it.
格蕾丝路线上有一位前女友，那是她几十年前交往过的人。今天早些时候，她在她家扔掉了一份批量邮件。在告诉我这件事之前，她停顿了一下。
She lost a child several years ago during the pandemic, and that kid got a piece of bulk mail today. So I was able to throw it away without her seeing it, because I know. And I was very grateful for that, being able to discard that piece of mail for her today so she didn't have to see her dead kid's name when she got her mail today. That felt really good.
她在疫情期间失去了一个孩子，而那个孩子今天收到了一份批量邮件。所以我能趁她没看到就把它扔掉，因为我知道情况。我对此感到非常庆幸，今天能为她丢弃那份邮件，这样她在收信时就不必看到她已故孩子的名字。那感觉真的很棒。
But with all these customers on her route, there are some that do this thing that just gets under Grace's skin.
但在她的路线上，有些客户做的一件事总是让格蕾丝感到厌烦。
So this situation-- yeah.
就是这种情况——没错。
She opens a mailbox jammed full of mail.
她打开了一个塞满信件的信箱。
So this never gets-- none of this mail will ever get picked up. See how much.
所以这些永远不会——这些邮件没一件会被取走。看看有多少。
Now, just describe what you just pulled out of that mailbox.
现在，描述一下你刚从信箱里拿出来的东西。
So this is a whole bunch of what one might call junk mail-- coupons.
这是一大堆人们所谓的垃圾邮件——优惠券。
She holds up a stack of these thick weekly advertising mailers.
她举起了一叠厚厚的每周广告传单。
So this is five weeks' worth. And I've definitely put packages in here, and they come out.
这攒了五周了。我肯定往这儿放过包裹，它们又被拿出来了。
So they're checking.
所以他们是有在检查的。
They look in to see if there's anything they want. And then if there's something they want, they take it out. But it makes it kind of hard to deliver mail when it's packed full, you know? Like, who do you expect to clean up after you? Who's gonna come-- your mom-- and empty your mailbox for you? Like, just get your mail. And I just find it very inconsiderate.
他们往里看，看有没有他们想要的。如果有想要的，他们就拿走。但信箱塞满了，送信就很困难，你懂吗？谁来帮你清理？你妈妈吗？谁会来帮你清空信箱？去把你的信取走。我觉得这很不体谅人。
On another street, we walk up to a house with a hand-painted sign in the window saying "Palestine will be free." It also usually has mail stuffed in its mailbox for weeks, including their mail-in ballots.
在另一条街上，我们走到一户人家门前，窗户上挂着手写的牌子，写着“巴勒斯坦将获得自由”。那里的信箱里通常也塞满了数周未取的邮件，包括他们的邮寄选票。
And they would walk by every day for a week and a half, walk right by the ballot, sticking right out of the mailbox.
他们每天走过去，持续了一周半，就在选票旁边走过，选票直接露在信箱外面。
That mailbox right there.
就是那个信箱。
So you could see it from the street. You could see the ballot.
所以从街上就能看到。你能看到那张选票。
You can see it from the street, and you can see it when you walk by. It's very, very easy to grab on the way in. But they didn't manage to do that for weeks.
从街上就能看到，走过去的时候也能看到。进门时顺手拿出来非常非常容易。但他们几周了都没做到。
And what did you think of that?
你对此怎么想？
I don't know-- I wonder what it's like to go through life not seeing things around you.
我不知道——我好奇一个人怎么能视而不见地度过一生。
But it's very possible that they see, but just the mail is not important to them at all.
但很有可能他们看到了，只是邮件对他们来说一点都不重要。
Right, and I understand that if it was full of crap, but they obviously care about politics. And I consider my ballot a sacred object, kind of. And they just kept walking by and walking by. It's not like it's heavy. It's not like it's cumbersome. It's just a matter of not caring at all or not seeing it. I don't know which.
对，如果里面全是废纸我也理解，但他们显然关心政治。我把我的选票看作神圣的物品。他们就这样走过来走过去。那又不重，又不麻烦。这要么是完全不在乎，要么是根本没看见。我不知道是哪一个。
Does it make you mad?
这会让你生气吗？
Sometimes, yeah. I can, actually-- I was telling someone the other day that I can kind of gauge my mood by a specific mailbox that I get to because it's always full. And if it doesn't bother me that much, I know I'm doing well that day. But if I get into a rage about it, I know that something's bothering me. You know what I'm saying? I can check back in my life and figure out what's making me so mad, because that mailbox will really anger me.
有时会，是的。我告诉别人说，我能通过特定的信箱来衡量我的情绪，因为它总是满的。如果这不怎么困扰我，说明我那天心情不错。但如果我因此暴怒，说明有什么事在困扰我。你懂我的意思吗？我可以回顾自己的生活，找出让我如此生气的原因，因为那个信箱真的会让我抓狂。
Grace has been doing this long enough-- over two decades-- starting before the internet really kicked in fully. And she remembers when everyone's relationship to their mail was different, before so much was on email. There were tons of business letters, first class mail, magazines back then. She was carrying way more of that, instead of what she carries now.
格蕾丝做这行已经很久了——超过二十年了——开始于互联网全面普及之前。她记得在电子邮件盛行之前，每个人与邮件的关系是不同的。那时有大量的商业信件、一等邮件和杂志。那时候她投递的邮件比现在多得多。
As far as what I consider crap-- that's just ads-- I guess it's probably 85%, 90% of what I deliver, if you exclude the parcels, because they're just the crap that people bought 'cause the ad told them to. [LAUGHS]
至于我所谓的垃圾——那些只是广告——我猜大概占了我投递量的85%到90%，如果不算包裹的话，因为那只是人们因为广告说要买才买的垃圾。[笑]
I mean, it's funny 'cause when this country was founded, the mail was the internet.
我的意思是，很有趣，因为当这个国家建立时，邮件就是互联网。
Yes.
是的。
Benjamin Franklin could get any job he wanted in the new government. And he's like, I want to be the postmaster.
本杰明·富兰克林可以在新政府里得到他想要的任何职位。但他却说，我想当邮政局长。
Yeah, communications. Yeah.
没错，通讯行业。是的。
'Cause it's being like Steve Jobs or something.
因为那就像当史蒂夫·乔布斯之类的。
It is. Right, it was. And there's still vestiges of that self-importance this agency still has. They told us in training that if an ambulance, a fire truck, a police car, and a postal truck all come to a four-way stop at the same time, who has the right of way? The postal truck. That somehow that's actually true in the Constitution, which is hilarious.
确实。没错，就是这样。而且这个机构至今仍保留着那种自我重要性的遗迹。培训时他们告诉我们，如果救护车、消防车、警车和邮政车同时到达一个四路交叉口，谁有先行权？是邮政车。这在宪法里居然是真的，简直太搞笑了。
Do you have this feeling of, like, you have this job that used to be a kind of noble calling and snow nor rain nor gloom of night, and then it moved from delivering stuff that people really, really wanted and needed and was essential to just delivering a lot of garbage?
你是否觉得，你的这份工作曾经是一种崇高使命——“无论风雨雪夜”——而现在却从投递人们真正想要、需要和必需的东西，变成了只投递大量的垃圾？
Yeah, totally. It's kind of achingly true that a lot of what we deliver is just garbage that people don't want. And you have to make your peace with the theory that that's the revenue that sustains the important work of-- because what we actually offer is dependability. We come every day.
是的，完全是。令人难过的是，我们投递的大部分确实只是人们不想要的垃圾。你必须接受这样一个理论：正是这些收入支撑了这项重要的工作——因为我们真正提供的是可靠性。我们每天都会来。
So if you have a return or whatever, you just put it out there. We take it right there. We know who you are, and we know the name. We know the people who used to live there. And I know where to take their mail. Grandma sends them something, and they move three times in between-- I can get it to them. We do that all the time at work. We know people so much better than any other delivery services.
所以如果你有退件或者其他什么，你只要把它放在那儿。我们就在那儿取走。我们知道你是谁，我们也知道名字。我们知道以前住在那儿的人。我知道把他们的邮件送到哪儿。奶奶寄给他们的东西，他们搬了三次家——我都能送到他们手里。我们在工作中经常这样做。我们比任何其他快递服务都更了解人们。
So you feel proud of your job.
所以你为你的工作感到自豪。
Yeah, yeah, Yeah. I mean, I really do like it. I really do think it's important. You have to, because it's every day for years and years and years, you know?
是的，是的。我是说，我真的很喜欢它。我确实认为它很重要。你必须这么认为，因为这是一年又一年每一天的重复，你懂吗？
When it comes to the mail that we think of when we think of the mail that we want to get, it's letters, personal letters, the old-fashioned kind, where somebody pours out their heart to somebody else by hand. I asked Grace to comb through the 25 pounds of stuff she was carrying for this one block swing on her route to see if she could find even one handwritten, personal letter.
说到我们想要的那些邮件，是指信件，私人信件，老式的那种，有人亲手写下内心深处的想法。我让格蕾丝在这一段路线上清点她背的25磅重的东西，看看能不能找到一封手写的私人信件。
Let's see. Financial, financial, secret to wealth-- I guess we'd call that financial. That's a bill. That's another bill. Insurance reminder, bill, political. No. Zero fun mail on this block today.
我看看。金融、金融、财富秘诀——我猜这叫金融。那是账单。那是另一张账单。保险提醒、账单、政治传单。没有。今天这一段路上零封有趣邮件。
This day, over the course of the entire day, over 350 homes, she delivered only three personal, handwritten letters.
这一天，在350多户人家里，她总共只投递了三封私人手写信件。
Do you write letters?
你写信吗？
No. Every once in a while, I do. I feel so proud of myself. Probably once every five years. [CHUCKLES] I really wish I was more of a letter writer.
不。偶尔写写。我为自己感到自豪。大概每五年写一次。[轻笑] 我真的很希望自己能更常写信。
Wait, why do you wish you were a letter writer?
等等，为什么你希望自己是个写信的人？
Because it seems like such a great hobby. When I do write one, I feel extremely good. It's a nice exercise. It's nice to imagine the person getting it. It's wonderful if they write you back. It's one of those things I'm like, oh, I should do more of this, but I just don't.
因为这似乎是一个很棒的爱好。当我写信时，我感觉非常好。这是一个不错的练习。想象一下对方收到信的样子是很美好的。如果他们回信就更棒了。这是那种我会想“哦，我应该多做些这种事”的事情，但我就是没做。
I don't know. I feel like I have the same impulse sometimes to write somebody, but then I really just type it and send the email, you know?
我不知道。我觉得我有时也有同样的冲动去写信，但最后真的只是打字发了邮件，你懂吗？
Yeah, correct.
是的，没错。
And that seems to be the same feeling.
感觉好像是一样的。
It's not, though. Try writing a letter sometime. You'll see how different it is. Different parts of your brain come out. You say things you wouldn't say. And plus, getting the physical thing from the other person, it's more-- there's a connection that the physicality of the letter brings a connection.
其实并不一样。尝试写一次信吧。你会发现有多不同。你大脑的不同部分会被调动起来。你会说出平时不会说的话。而且，收到对方寄来的实体物品，那种联系感——书信的物理存在带来了一种连接。
I don't have sentimentality for that part of it, but it's undeniable that getting a letter, a real letter, is exciting. It's rare. The kind of letter where somebody sat down-- "dear you, from me"-- and really tried to say something that needed to be said, where they're putting something into words for the very first time or correcting the record or trying to persuade. And they know it's going to go better if they do it in writing.
对于这一部分，我并没有多愁善感，但不可否认的是，收到一封信，一封真正的信，是令人兴奋的。这很罕见。那种某人坐下来——“亲爱的你，来自我”——真心实意地想要表达出需要被说出的话，他们第一次把某些东西诉诸文字，或者澄清事实，或者试图说服。而且他们知道，如果用书面形式来表达，效果会更好。
Today, on our show, we dive into all sorts of dramas, laid out on the page. Today we have sincere letters, funny letters, and one letter on a big, life changing mission. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Sincerely yours, Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天，在我们的节目中，我们将深入探讨页面上展开的各种戏剧性事件。今天我们有真诚的信件、有趣的信件，还有一封肩负重大改变人生使命的信件。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。诚挚地，艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, "Dear Alice." So we start with this letter, which is very much somebody trying to figure out something that has been hard to figure out. It's written by Nicole Piasecki about something that happened when she was in high school. Here's Nicole.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕，“亲爱的爱丽丝”。我们从这封信开始，这确实是某人在试图理清一些一直难以理清的事情。这是妮可·皮亚塞基写的，关于她高中时发生的一件事。下面有请妮可。
Dear Alice,
亲爱的爱丽丝，
1. I've started to write this letter at least 20 times in as many years, which is way too much time. I need to find a way to finally be done with this. The only way I've ever gotten close is by writing in fragments.
1. 过去二十年里，我至少写了20遍这封信，这已经浪费太多时间了。我得找个方法彻底结束它。我唯一接近成功的方法就是写成碎片。
2. When I first walked into your high school English class in Chelsea, Michigan, school had been a struggle for me. Every class felt focused on how fast you could do something and how right you could be. Yours wasn't.
2. 当我第一次走进你在密歇根州切尔西高中的英语教室时，学校生活对我来说是一场挣扎。每门课似乎都关注你做得有多快，有多正确。你的不是。
I still remember the one afternoon senior year. We'd finished a vocabulary quiz. You said, "Open your notebooks, and close your eyes." We looked at you strangely at first, but we trusted you enough to follow along. You dimmed the lights.
我至今仍记得高三的一个下午。我们做完了词汇测验。你说：“打开笔记本，闭上眼睛。”起初我们看你的眼神很奇怪，但我们足够信任你，于是照做了。你调暗了灯光。
"Imagine you're walking alone through the depths of a woodland forest," you said. We could hear you slowly pacing and your long, sensible skirt swaying with each step. You guided us along a path in the woods, pointing to tiny mushrooms, a toad at the water's edge.
“想象你正独自走在茂密的林地深处，”你说。我们可以听到你在缓慢地踱步，你那条舒适的长裙随着每一步摇曳。你引导我们走在林间小路上，指着细小的蘑菇，水边的一只蟾蜍。
Eventually, you told us to open our eyes and to start writing, to keep describing whatever wilderness we'd conjured in our minds. No teacher had ever asked me to write something from my own imagination, and I loved it. I started keeping a journal. Everyone, if they're lucky, has at least one teacher who changes their life or makes them feel at home in school. That's who you were to me-- my favorite teacher.
最后，你让我们睁开眼睛，开始写作，继续描述我们在脑海中构建出的荒野。从未有老师要求我从自己的想象中写点什么，我喜欢这种感觉。我开始写日记。每个人如果幸运的话，都会有一位改变他们人生或让他们在学校感到宾至如归的老师。你就是我心里的那个人——我最喜欢的老师。
3. I'd never given much thought to my teachers' lives outside of school. You were a fixture in that corner classroom, a woman who seemed to exist wholly there. I never would have imagined that you were married to a man who kept a gun beneath his pillow.
3. 我从未想过老师在校外的生活。你是那个角落教室里的常客，一个仿佛只存在于那里的女性。我从未想到你会嫁给一个把枪放在枕头底下的男人。
4. I took Chemistry I with your husband in 1992 when I was a sophomore. He wore that plaid and wool hunting jacket and drank coffee out of that small, plastic cup that doubled as a lid to his tall vacuum thermos. His hands sometimes shook when he lifted the cup to his lips.
4. 1992年我上高二时，选了你丈夫的化学I课。他穿着那件格子毛呢猎装，用那个既是盖子又是小杯子的塑料杯喝咖啡。当他把杯子递到嘴边时，手有时会颤抖。
He kept his haggard ponytail pulled back with a thin rubber band. I remember that he played loud rock music on the stereo while we did experiments. Though I interpreted his personality as arrogant and strange, I didn't dislike him as much as I quietly despised the subject of chemistry. You should know that I've always struggled with solving complicated formulas.
他用橡皮筋束着那条凌乱的马尾辫。我记得我们在做实验时，他会在音响里播放大声的摇滚乐。虽然我把他的人格解读为傲慢且奇怪，但我并不讨厌他，就像我默默鄙视化学这门学科一样。你应该知道，我一直不擅长解复杂的公式。
5. My dad never told me things that a teenager didn't need to know, and I never thought to ask very many questions. He mostly kept his work life separate from his home life. I didn't know what a school superintendent did all day, and I never thought to ask him.
5. 我爸爸从不告诉我青少年不需要知道的事，我也从未想过要多问。他大多把工作和家庭生活分开。我不知道学校学监每天在做什么，也从没想过要问他。
One night, though, when I was standing in our kitchen by the sliding glass door, my dad walked up to me with his hands in the pockets of his faded weekend jeans and said, "Hey, Nic, when you went in early for chemistry help, did Mr. Leith ever act weird around you?" I looked at my dad for a few seconds and wrinkled my brow.
不过有一天晚上，当我站在厨房滑动玻璃门边时，爸爸把手插在褪色的周末牛仔裤口袋里，对我说道：“嘿，尼克，你早去化学课寻求辅导的时候，莱斯先生对你有没有什么奇怪的举动？”我盯着爸爸看了几秒钟，皱起了眉头。
Then I defended your husband. "What are you talking about?" I replied. My dad dropped the subject without explanation, and I quickly forgot about it. Even when it was just the two of us, your husband and I in his chemistry lab, he had never said anything inappropriate to me. I wasn't a pretty girl. I was self-conscious and tomboyish. Acne spotted my jawline and chin. My chest was as flat as a boy's. And I was the boss's daughter.
接着我为你的丈夫辩护。“你在说什么呀？”我回答。爸爸没做解释就转移了话题，我也很快就忘了这件事。即使只有我们两人，你丈夫和我单独在他的化学实验室里，他也从未对我做过任何不适当的事。我不是个漂亮女孩。我很自卑，像个假小子。粉刺长在我的下颌线和下巴上。我的胸部像男孩一样平。而且我是老板的女儿。
6. Earlier that year, the mother of a quiet, long-haired senior girl called our home telephone at an unusually late hour. I answered the call in the kitchen. "Dad, it's for you," I said, in the direction of the living room. He took the call in private.
6. 那年早些时候，一个文静、长发的高三女孩的母亲在深夜给我们家打了电话。我在厨房接了电话。“爸爸，找你的。”我朝着客厅的方向喊。他在私下接了那通电话。
7. One of my favorite photographs of my dad is the one where he's sitting next to my hospital bed at St. Joe's in Ypsilanti right after my knee surgery during my senior year. He sat in that uncomfortable chair, staying day and night as my left leg moved, bending and straightening in a constant passive motion machine. He only stepped out of the room when the nurse arrived to help me use the bedpan.
7. 我最喜欢的一张爸爸的照片，是他坐在我在伊普西兰蒂圣约瑟夫医院的病床旁，那是我高三膝盖手术后。他坐在那张不舒服的椅子上，日夜守着我的左腿，它在被动运动机器上不断地弯曲、伸直。只有当护士来帮我用便盆时，他才会走出房间。
In the photograph, he's wearing jeans and a blue sweater with a tired, loyal smile on his face. Back then, I never saw his commitment to me as remarkable because it was all I had known.
照片里，他穿着牛仔裤和蓝色毛衣，脸上挂着疲惫而忠诚的笑容。那时，我从没觉得他对我的奉献有什么了不起，因为那是我所知道的一切。
8. Surely you know all about the giddiness that your high school students felt on the Thursday before Christmas break. My energy that day felt boundless. I practically bounced from seventh period across the grass and straight to the outer window of my dad's office.
8. 你肯定知道高中生在圣诞假前最后一个周四的那种兴奋感。那天我的精力感觉无穷无尽。我几乎是从第七节课一路跳着穿过草坪，直奔爸爸办公室外侧的窗户。
I knocked on his window, and he tilted it open. He was eating an ice cream sundae from McDonald's out of a small, clear plastic cup. He smiled his full face smile when he saw me, and I returned a grin. He reached out and dropped the car keys into my hand so I could drive to physical therapy. As I turned to walk toward the parking lot, my dad said, "Have fun. See you later," and tipped the window to close it.
我敲了敲窗户，他把它推开。他正在吃从麦当劳买的圣代，用的是透明小塑料杯。看到我时，他露出了灿烂的笑容，我也回以微笑。他伸手把车钥匙扔到我手里，好让我开车去物理治疗。当我转身走向停车场时，爸爸说：“玩得开心。回头见。”然后拉上窗户关好。
At physical therapy, my friend, Carey, and I both rode Stairmasters, and we listened to the Lemonheads album It's a Shame About Ray on the stereo. We moved our arms like we were dancing. The snow fell quietly outside. The cold windows had white paper snowflakes Scotch taped to them.
在物理治疗中心，我的朋友凯莉和我都骑着楼梯机，听着音响里播放的柠檬头合唱团的《It’s a Shame About Ray》。我们挥动双臂，就像在跳舞。雪静静地落在外面。寒冷的窗户上用透明胶带贴着白纸剪的雪花。
Mid-workout, we overheard someone say there had been a shooting at Chelsea High School. We stepped off the Stairmasters and huddled around an AM/FM radio to try to learn more. At first, we were worried about our friends who might have been at a game in the school gym. We imagine that the shooter must have been a kid from another school. It never crossed our minds that the shooter could have been your husband or the victim could have been my dad.
运动中途，我们无意中听到有人说切尔西高中发生了枪击事件。我们走下楼梯机，挤在收音机旁想了解更多信息。起初，我们担心在学校健身房参加比赛的朋友们。我们以为枪手一定是别的学校的学生。我们从未想过枪手可能是你的丈夫，受害者可能是我爸爸。
9. When the details of that afternoon that your husband killed my dad slowly leaked out from police reports and school employees, I learned that your husband had been reprimanded for sexually harassing female students in the hallways. I learned that he was on the verge of losing his job. I learned that your husband had stormed out of a grievance meeting with administrators not long after the school day had ended.
9. 当那天下午你丈夫杀害我爸爸的细节从警方的报告和学校职员口中慢慢流出时，我了解到你的丈夫因在走廊里性骚扰女学生而受到训斥。我了解到他濒临失去工作的边缘。我了解到你的丈夫在放学后不久，就愤然离开了与行政人员的申诉会议。
I learned that you and your husband carpooled home from school together that day. I learned that you were with him and his anger for the 20 minutes it took you to drive home. I learned that when you arrived home, your husband disappeared upstairs. He returned with a 9 millimeter semi-automatic pistol in his hand. He asserted, "He is going to die."
我了解到，那天你和丈夫是一起拼车回家的。我了解到，在他开车的20分钟里，你一直和他以及他的愤怒在一起。我了解到，当你到家时，你的丈夫消失在楼上。他手里拿着一把9毫米半自动手枪回来。他声称：“他会死的。”
I learned that your husband got back into the car alone and sped toward the school administration building, where my dad and two others continued the meeting. 20 minutes-- that's how long it took your husband to drive back to the high school.
我了解到，你的丈夫独自回到车里，飞速驶向学校的行政大楼，我爸爸和其他两人还在那里继续开会。20分钟——那是你丈夫开车回到高中所需的时间。
I learned that you didn't call the police, whose small-town headquarters were less than a five-minute drive away from the school. You didn't call the administration building to warn the three men whose lives were at stake-- sitting ducks. Instead, you called the teachers' union office in Ann Arbor, 20 minutes in the opposite direction.
我了解到，你没有给警察打电话，他们的总部就在离学校不到五分钟车程的小镇上。你没有给行政大楼打电话警告那三个人，他们的生命危在旦夕——他们就像活靶子。相反，你给20分钟路程外反方向的安娜堡教师工会办公室打了电话。
Your husband wore a long coat with pockets of ammunition. He squealed his tires in the school parking lot. He told someone who approached him that he had, quote, "unfinished business to attend to." He walked into the administration building, turned the corner into the doorway of the small office.
你的丈夫穿着长外套，口袋里装满了弹药。他在学校停车场尖叫着踩下刹车。他告诉走近他的人说，他有“未完成的公事要办”。他走进行政大楼，转过拐角走进小办公室的门口。
He lifted the gun and pointed it first at my dad-- Daddy, Dada, Pops. My 47-year-old dad's last words were, "Steve, you don't have to do this." Your husband fired round after round. He killed my dad. He injured two others. You didn't call the police.
他举起枪，先对准了我爸爸——爸爸，达达，波普。我47岁爸爸最后的遗言是：“史蒂夫，你没必要这样做。”你的丈夫开了又开。他杀了我爸爸。他还伤了另外两人。你没有打给警察。
10. Why, Alice? Why the [BLEEP] didn't you call the police? Why? Why? Why?
10. 为什么，爱丽丝？为什么该死的你不打给警察？为什么？为什么？为什么？
11. After your husband shot my dad, a pocket of time existed where my dad was gone, and it was still just a Thursday in December. I was still just a teenager, happily riding the Stairmaster at MedSport, looking through icy windows with paper snowflakes taped to them.
11. 在你丈夫射杀我爸爸之后，存在着一段空隙，我爸爸已经不在了，但那依然只是十二月的一个周四。我依然只是一个十几岁的青少年，快乐地骑着楼梯机，看着贴着纸雪花的冰冷窗户。
My brother, Brian, was still just a fresh-faced Private First Class wrenching bolts on the engines of fleet vehicles at a Marine base in North Carolina. My mom was still a wife of 25 years and a middle school special education teacher at a neighboring school district. And you were still just my favorite teacher, the one who let us write about an imaginary forest.
我的哥哥布莱恩，依然只是一个年轻的一等兵，在北卡罗来纳州的海军陆战队基地修理车辆引擎。我的妈妈依然是一个结婚25年的妻子，是邻近学区的一名中学特殊教育教师。而你，依然是我最喜欢的老师，那个让我们写想象森林的老师。
12. I can't remember if it was you or I who initiated the meeting a few days after your husband murdered my dad at our school. I hadn't slept since I found out. I had been desperately pulling his photographs from sticky plastic pages of family photo albums and taping them to the bathroom mirrors.
12. 我记不清是在你丈夫谋杀我爸爸几天后，在我们学校是谁发起的会面。自打知道消息后，我就再没睡过觉。我绝望地从家庭相册粘糊糊的塑料页中抽出他的照片，把它们贴在浴室的镜子上。
Still, I was worried about how you might be feeling. I was eager to believe in you, to affirm that we were both unknowing victims of your husband's violent actions, to tell you that I didn't blame you. I sensed some hesitation from my mom, but she took me to meet you anyway. The story was still developing. I couldn't imagine any scenario wherein you were not the hero. She could.
尽管如此，我还是很担心你的感受。我渴望相信你，确认我们都是你丈夫暴力行为下不知情的受害者，告诉你不怪你。我从妈妈那里感觉到了一丝犹豫，但她还是带我去见你了。故事还在发展中。我无法想象任何一种你不是英雄的情景。她能。
We learned that since the shooting, you had been staying with your friend and colleague, Pam. When we arrived at her house, Pam took our damp jackets, and I saw you sitting alone in a wingback chair at the far corner of the large room. You didn't rise to greet us when we entered the Christmas-ready living room. Your face displayed a low, distant gaze. Your fingertips fidgeted with a pinch of fabric on the bottom of your sweater. I don't know what kind of a welcome I had expected, but it wasn't this.
我们得知，枪击发生后，你一直住在你的朋友兼同事帕姆家。当我们到达她家时，帕姆接过了我们潮湿的外套，我看到你独自坐在宽大房间角落里的翼背椅上。当我们走进洋溢着圣诞气氛的客厅时，你没有起身迎接。你的脸上带着一种疏离的凝视。你的指尖摆弄着毛衣下摆的一点布料。我不知道自己预想的是什么样的欢迎，但绝不是这样。
Finally, you approached me. You said something like, "This is for you," and your tone was solemn. You reached out and handed me a hardcover book and a handwritten letter. Do you remember the title? Did the book have a tree on the cover? I never read the book. I meant to. My head was too clouded with grief in those days to concentrate for long. I stuffed the book into a drawer in my bedroom and never looked at it again.
最后，你向我走来。你说了句类似“这是给你的”之类的话，语气很庄重。你伸出手，递给我一本精装书和一封手写信。你还记得那本书的名字吗？封面上有棵树吗？我从没读过那本书。我本打算读的。那段日子里，我的头脑被悲伤笼罩，无法长时间集中注意力。我把书塞进卧室的抽屉里，就再也没看过。
I did read your short letter. Your words were scrawled diagonally across a yellow legal paper that you had folded like a business letter. The one thing I'd always remembered about that letter was the part I understood the least. "Maybe we can make a circle someday," it said. I've been wanting to ask you for years. What does that mean?
我确实读了你的短笺。你的文字斜着潦草地写在一张黄色的法律信纸上，像商业信函一样折叠着。我一直记得那封信里的一件事，就是我最理解不了的部分。“也许有一天我们可以画个圈，”上面写着。这些年来我一直想问你。那是什么意思？
13. I returned to school only three weeks after my dad died, often arriving late and unprepared, driving up to the school in the used Chevy Corsica that was still registered in his name. My other teachers offered me unspoken allowances for my unimpressive academic performance during the second half of my senior year. My government teacher passed my late biased research paper that took a stance against the death penalty. I called capital punishment, quote, "an option that doesn't warrant enough suffering."
13. 我在爸爸去世仅三周后就回到了学校，常常迟到，没做准备，开着那辆依然登记在爸爸名下的二手雪佛兰科西嘉。其他老师在我高三下半学期学术表现平平的情况下，给予我默许的宽容。我的政府课老师让我那篇反对死刑的、带有偏见的迟交研究论文通过了。我称死刑为“一个不需要承担太多痛苦的选择”。
I was scheduled to return to your English class, but the counselor intervened. Instead, I met with your student teacher in the library every day. I don't remember her name, only that her severe psoriasis frightened and distracted me. I was afraid it was contagious, and I couldn't bear any other complications in my life.
我本该回到你的英语班，但辅导员干预了。相反，我每天在图书馆和你的一位实习教师见面。我不记得她的名字，只记得她严重的牛皮癣吓到了我，让我分心。我怕那是传染性的，我无法承受生活中有任何其他麻烦了。
We read Hemingway's The Old Man and the Sea as an independent study. I remember how tired Santiago was while trying to reel that large marlin into the boat. I wouldn't have had it in me to keep going like he did. The final semester of high school, I don't remember speaking to you. Surely, I must have seen you in the hallways. Did you see me?
我们作为独立研究读了海明威的《老人与海》。我记得圣地亚哥在努力把那条大马林鱼拉上船时有多累。我就没有像他那样坚持下去的毅力。高中的最后一个学期，我不记得跟你说过话。我肯定在走廊里见过你。你看见我了吗？
14. It was confusing to see you in the courtroom on the opposing side, sitting next to your mother-in-law, then taking the stand, making a case for your husband's insanity defense, trying to keep him out of prison. The defense attorney led you through a detailed account of your husband's bizarre actions.
14. 在法庭上看到你站在对立面，坐在你婆婆旁边，然后走上证人席，为丈夫的精神失常辩护，试图让他免于入狱，这让人感到困惑。辩护律师引导你详述了你丈夫的怪异行为。
I remember the story of your husband killing your pet bird, how he broke its neck with his bare hands. You recounted a holiday when he curled himself beneath a piano and sobbed like a baby. You explained his obsession with guns, how he usually kept one within reach.
我还记得你丈夫杀死你们宠物鸟的故事，他是怎么用双手扭断它的脖子的。你讲述了一个节日，他蜷缩在钢琴下面像婴儿一样哭泣。你解释了他对枪支的痴迷，他是如何总是把枪放在触手可及的地方。
An aisle in the courtroom divided my family from his, yours. You never once looked across, at least not while I was looking. And you didn't look when the verdict was delivered-- guilty, life in prison without parole.
法庭上的一条过道把我的家人和你的家人分开了。你一次也没有看过来，至少在我看向那边的时候。当宣判——有罪，终身监禁且不得假释——时，你也没有看。
15. I know exactly where I was when I learned you lost your battle with cancer. I stood courtside in the main gymnasium at Adrian College. I wore my jersey, baggy white shorts, and a bulky knee brace. I had just finished playing a Division III basketball game. My mom came to watch my game because it was the second anniversary of the day your husband killed my dad. It seemed that we should be together.
15. 我清楚地记得得知你患癌去世时我在哪里。我站在艾德里安学院的主体育馆场边。我穿着队服，松垮的白色短裤，戴着厚重的护膝。我刚打完一场三级联盟的篮球比赛。妈妈来看我的比赛，因为那正好是你丈夫杀害我爸爸两周年的日子。我们似乎应该待在一起。
"I have some news," Mom said. She had done the right thing by waiting until after the game was over to tell me. "Alice died." "When?" I asked. "Her funeral was today."
“我有个消息，”妈妈说。她等比赛结束后再告诉我，这是正确的做法。“爱丽丝去世了。”“什么时候？”我问。“她的葬礼今天举行。”
16. Did you ever attend the National Council of Teachers of English convention? I've barely missed a year since I began my own career as an English teacher. You're gone, so I don't have to worry about running into you there in the elevator going up or the cafe at lunch.
16. 你有没有参加过全国英语教师委员会大会？自打我自己成为英语教师以来，我几乎没错过一年。你已经不在了，所以我不用担心在电梯里或午餐时的咖啡馆里遇见你了。
But I must admit that sometimes I think I see you places. I see a modestly dressed woman with shoulder-length brown hair and downward pointing chestnut eyes, and my breath catches in my throat. Then I remember. If only it was just in those moments that I thought of you. But I have a classroom like you had a classroom. And the books I sometimes turn to in my thoughts, I first read in your class.
但我必须承认，有时我觉得我在某处看到了你。我看到一位着装朴素、留着及肩棕发、眼神下垂呈栗色的女性，我就感到呼吸一窒。然后我记起来了。要是只有在那一瞬间想到你该多好。但我也有自己的教室，就像你曾经有过的一样。而我有时在思绪中翻开的书，最初都是在你的课上读到的。
17. The last time I saw you in the flesh, I was a freshman at Adrian College. And you were still an English teacher at Chelsea High School. In a moment of capriciousness, I drove the hour north on Michigan 52 and parked in a visitor's space in front of the high school. All the students sat in class, which left me alone to walk the cement pathways.
17. 我最后一次亲眼见到你，是我在艾德里安学院读大一的时候。你当时依然是切尔西高中的英语老师。一时冲动，我开车向北走了那一小时的56号公路，停在了高中前的访客停车位。所有学生都在上课，这让我能独自走在水泥小路上。
It still seems strange that life just continued on in that place. A different teacher stood in front of your husband's old classroom. A new superintendent sat at a desk in my dad's old office. New kids replaced those of us who had graduated.
那个地方的生活竟然还在继续，这感觉依然奇怪。不同的老师站在你丈夫的老教室前。新的学监坐在我爸爸的老办公室里。新的孩子们取代了我们这些已经毕业的学生。
I entered the English building and walked down the locker-encased hallway to your classroom. I peeked into your classroom window, a thin, rectangular pane of glass. I saw you leaning on a desk just a few feet from the door, helping a small group of students. I stared through the window until you saw me. When you looked up, your body froze for a moment. I wonder what you were thinking then.
我走进英语教学楼，沿着锁柜林立的走廊走向你的教室。我窥视了你教室的窗户，那是一块细长的矩形玻璃片。我看到你倚在办公桌上，离门只有几英尺远，正在辅导一小群学生。我一直盯着窗户，直到你看见了我。当你抬头时，身体僵硬了一会儿。我好奇那时你在想什么。
I hadn't told anyone that I was coming and still find it hard to explain my motivation to see you that day. You looked weak, frail, sick, a dimmer version of your former self. I remember that you stepped into the hallway and faced me. You looked me straight in the eyes. You wore an expression that I decoded as a combination of compassion and fear.
我没告诉任何人我要来，至今也很难解释那天去见你的动机。你看上去虚弱、憔悴、生病，是过去自己的一个模糊版本。我记得你走到走廊上，面对我。你直视我的眼睛。你的表情被我解读为同情与恐惧的混合体。
Even with your full attention, I couldn't speak a single word. All I could do is stand in the hallway and look at you, standing three feet away. I searched your face and eyes, and you searched mine, as if all the questions were written there. You never asked me why I had come. You seemed to understand, maybe more than I did. How long did we stand there saying nothing at all?
即使你全神贯注地看着我，我也说不出半个字。我只能站在走廊里看着你，站在三英尺远的地方。我搜索你的面孔和眼睛，你也搜索我的，仿佛所有的疑问都写在那里。你从没问过我为什么要来。你似乎理解，也许比我理解得还要深。我们那样一言不发地站了多久？
18. I never figured out what you meant when you wrote, "Maybe we can make a circle someday," in the letter you handed me. Over time, I got angry at you for saying something so cryptic to a 17-year-old.
18. 我从来没弄明白你在递给我的那封信里写的“也许有一天我们可以画个圈”是什么意思。随着时间的推移，我因为你对一个17岁的孩子说了这样晦涩的话而生你的气。
Did you plan to tell me something later, after the trial? Something that would have closed the space between us? I can't, even after all these drafts, imagine what that could be. What words could possibly have accomplished that? Maybe you never figured it out either.
你是不是计划在审判后晚些时候告诉我什么？什么能缩小我们之间鸿沟的话？即使写了这么多草稿，我也无法想象那会是什么。什么样的话可能做到这一点？也许连你自己也从没想出来。
Sincerely, Nicole.
诚挚地，妮可。
Nicole Piasecki. She's a writer and also a writing teacher at the University of Colorado, Denver. A version of her letter was first published in Hippocampus Magazine. The radio version of her letter was produced by Chris Benderev.
妮可·皮亚塞基。她是一位作家，也是丹佛科罗拉多大学的写作教师。她的信件版本首次发表在《海马杂志》上。她信件的广播版由克里斯·本德列夫制作。
Act Two, "Dear Miss." So there's this thing that's been happening now and then on stage for over a decade in London and elsewhere called Letters Live inspired by this book by Shaun Usher, Letters of Note, they get performers, including some ridiculously famous actors, to read letters written by people like Gandhi, David Bowie and Freida Kahlo and James Baldwin and lots of other famous people as well.
第二幕，“亲爱的女士”。在伦敦和其他地方，过去十多年里舞台上偶尔会发生一件名为“书信现场”的事情，灵感来自于肖恩·亚瑟的那本书《书信备忘录》，他们请表演者，包括一些非常出名的演员，来朗读像甘地、大卫·鲍伊、弗里达·卡罗、詹姆斯·鲍德温以及许多其他名人的信件。
This next letter is one of those, somebody who is not famous. It was written back when letters were king, before telephones even, in 1866, in Yorkshire in the north of England, from a farmer named Simon Fallowfield to a woman named Mary Foster. It's read by the actor Taron Egerton, who's maybe best known for Kingsman and for starring as Elton John in Rocketman.
下一封信就是其中之一，来自一位不出名的人。它写于书信为王的年代，在电话发明之前，1866年，在英格兰北部的约克郡，由一位名叫西蒙·法洛菲尔德的农夫写给一位名叫玛丽·福斯特的女性。朗读者是演员塔伦·埃哲顿，他或许因《王牌特工》以及在《火箭人》中扮演艾尔顿·约翰而最广为人知。
My Dear Miss, I now take up my pen to write to you, hoping these few lines will find you well as it leaves me at present-- thank God for it. You will perhaps be surprised that I should make so bold as to write to you, who is such a lady. And I hope you will not be vexed at me for it. I hardly dare say what I want. I am so timid about ladies, and my heart trimmels like a hespin. But I once see'd in a book that faint heart never won fair lady, so here goes.
亲爱的女士，我现在提起笔给您写信，希望这几行字能像它此刻离开我时一样，让您一切安好——感谢上帝。您可能会惊讶我竟敢如此大胆地写信给您，您毕竟是一位如此尊贵的女士。希望您不要因此而烦恼。我几乎不敢说出我的想法。我对女士们太胆怯了，我的心跳得像只小兔子。但我曾在一本书里看到过，“胆小者永远赢不到佳人”，所以就这样吧。
I am a farmer in a small way, and my age is rather more than 40 years. And my mother lives with me and keeps my house. And she's been very poorly lately and cannot stir about much. And I think I should be more comfortable with a wife.
我是一个小规模的农夫，年纪四十有余了。我母亲和我住在一起，操持家务。她最近身体很差，走动不便。我想有个妻子会让我更舒服些。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I have had my eye on you a long time.
我注视您很久了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I think you are a very nice young woman and one that would make me happy if only you think so. We keep a servant girl to milk three kye and do the work in the house. And she goes on a bit in the summer to gadder wickens, and she snags a few turnips in the back kend.
我认为您是一位非常好的年轻女性，如果您的想法也一样的话，那一定会让我感到幸福。我们雇了一名女佣来挤三头奶牛并做家务。夏天她偶尔会出去采摘野草，在后院顺手挖些萝卜。
I do a piece of work on the farm myself and attends Pateley market. And I sometimes sow a few sheep, and I feeds between three and four pigs again Christmas. And the same is very useful in the house to make pies and cakes and so forth. And I sells the hams to help pay for the barley meal.
我自己也在农场干活，并参加帕特利集市。我有时会种些绵羊，我在圣诞节前喂养三到四头猪。这些东西在家里做馅饼、蛋糕之类的很有用。我卖掉火腿来支付大麦粉的费用。
I have about 73 pound in Naisbro Bank, and we have a nice little parlor downstairs with a blue carpet and an oven on the side of the fireplace and the old woman on the other side, smoking.
我在奈斯伯勒银行存了大概73英镑，我们楼下有一个漂亮的小客厅，铺着蓝色地毯，壁炉边有个烤箱，老太太在另一边吸烟。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The golden rules claimed up on the walls above the settle, and you could sit all day in the easy chair and knit and mend my kytles and leggums.
墙上的定居架上挂着金科玉律，您可以整天坐在舒适的椅子上织毛衣，修补我的裤子和绑腿。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And you could make the tea ready again I come in. And you could make butter for Pateley market. And I would drive you to church every Sunday in the spring cart. And I would do all that be's in my power to make you happy. So I hope to hear from you.
您可以准备好茶等我回来。您可以为帕特利集市制作黄油。每个周日我都会用马车送您去教堂。我会尽我所能让您快乐。所以我希望能收到您的回信。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I am in desprit and Yurnest and will marry you at May Day. Or if my mother dies afore, I shall want you afore.
我是真诚地渴望娶您为妻，定在五月节。如果我母亲在那之前去世，我希望您能更早嫁过来。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
If only you will accept of me, my dear, we could be very happy together. I hope you will let me know your mind by return of post. And if you are favorable, I will come up to scratch. So no more at present from your well-wisher and true love, Simon Fallowfield.
亲爱的，只要您接受我，我们在一起会非常快乐。希望您能尽快让我知道您的心意。如果您赞同，我就准备去提亲。那么就这样，来自您的祝愿者和真爱，西蒙·法洛菲尔德。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
PS, uh, I hope you will say nothing about this. If you will not accept of me, I have another very nice woman in my eye.
附言：呃，希望您不要声张。如果您不接受我，我还有另一位很不错的女性人选。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I think I shall marry her if you do not accept of me. But I thought you would suit my mother better, she being very crusty at times.
如果您不接受，我想我应该会娶她。但我认为您比她更适合我母亲，因为她老人家有时非常挑剔。
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
[笑声，掌声]
Taron Egerton reading at Letters Live. Apparently, Mary Foster, who got that letter, turned down this proposal of marriage. You can find videos of Olivia Colman, Benedict Cumberbatch, Brian Cox, Edie Falco, Jude Law, and so many other great actors reading letters at the Letters Live YouTube channel or at their website, letterslive.com. Their next show is going to be at the Royal Albert Hall in December.
塔伦·埃哲顿在“书信现场”朗读。显然，收到这封信的玛丽·福斯特拒绝了这个求婚。您可以在“书信现场”的YouTube频道或他们的网站letterslive.com上找到奥利维亚·科尔曼、本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇、布莱恩·考克斯、伊迪·法可、裘德·洛等许多伟大演员朗读信件的视频。他们的下一场演出将于十二月在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅举行。
Act Three, "Dear Dr. Kestenbaum." They tell you to never meet your heroes, but can you write to them? Not long after David Kestenbaum left his old job in particle physics, which he has a PhD in, and became a reporter, he tried just that.
第三幕，“亲爱的克里斯滕鲍姆博士”。人们告诉你永远不要去见你的偶像，但你可以写信给他们吗？大卫·克里斯滕鲍姆在辞掉粒子物理学工作并获得博士学位、成为一名记者后不久，就尝试了这一点。
When I was a young science journalist, I sent an email to one of the most famous physicists in the world. I was nervous about it. I was new to journalism. I did not know how to find stories. I still don't, really. But I figured, this is how real reporters operated. They developed sources. My goal was to get him on the phone.
当我是一名年轻的科学记者时，我给世界上最著名的物理学家之一发了一封电子邮件。我为此感到紧张。我刚接触新闻业。我不知道如何寻找故事。实际上，我现在也不知道。但我心想，真正的记者就是这样运作的。他们开发消息源。我的目标是让他接电话。
The physicist was a man named Peter Higgs in Scotland. Higgs was famous because way back in 1964, he'd written this paper proposing the possible existence of a new subatomic particle. Everyone in the field called it the Higgs particle-- well, except for one who wrote a book calling it "the God particle," though people kind of hated that name.
那位物理学家是苏格兰的彼得·希格斯。希格斯出名是因为早在1964年，他写了一篇论文，提出一种新的亚原子粒子可能存在。该领域的每个人都叫它希格斯粒子——好吧，除了一位写书称其为“上帝粒子”的人，尽管人们有点讨厌那个名字。
Anyway, it was a big deal if it did really exist. It could explain why other subatomic particles had mass, which you want them to. If electrons were massless, they would fly off. You couldn't have atoms. We would not be here. I'd been a physics grad student a few years before, and one of the things we had been searching for with this massive experiment was the Higgs particle.
总之，如果它真的存在，那将是一件大事。它能解释为什么其他亚原子粒子具有质量，这是你希望它们具有的属性。如果电子没有质量，它们就会飞走。你就无法拥有原子。我们也就不会出现在这里。几年前我曾是物理学研究生，我们那次大规模实验所寻找的东西之一就是希格斯粒子。
So, my goal was to get Peter Higgs, who maybe had seen this deep truth about the nature of the universe, on the phone. I needed some excuse, so I wrote that I was curious how the Higgs had come to have his name. Not a great question, but the only one I could think of. Would he have a few minutes to talk? I sent the email. The next day, no reply. A week went by. Two weeks.
所以，我的目标是让可能看透宇宙本质这种深层真理的彼得·希格斯接电话。我需要一个借口，于是我写道，我很好奇希格斯这个名字是怎么来的。这不是个好问题，但这是我能想到的唯一一个。他能有几分钟时间谈谈吗？我发出了邮件。第二天，没有回复。一周过去了。两周过去了。
And then, after about a month, the mailman came with a letter-- a letter. Actually, it was this thing called an aerogram that had been popular during World War II, a single lightweight page that folded over, lightweight because, you know, airmail, which is a funny thing to handwrite an overseas letter in response to an email. But he was an older guy at that point. I imagined his assistant printing out his emails for him.
然后，大概一个月后，邮递员带来了一封信——一封信。实际上，这是一种在二战期间很流行、被称为航空信笺的东西，是一种折叠起来的轻便单页纸，之所以轻便是因为，你知道，那是航空邮件。用手写这种海外信件来回复电子邮件是很滑稽的。但他当时已经是一位老人家了。我想象着他的助理在为他打印电子邮件。
I opened it up. It begins, "Dear Dr. Kestenbaum, thank you for your email message dated 9 December 1997." I remember being excited to get it, but also pretty quickly disappointed. It's a very boring letter. He did answer my question in a very detailed and technical way.
我打开它。开头是：“亲爱的克里斯滕鲍姆博士，感谢您1997年12月9日的电子邮件。”我记得收到信时很兴奋，但也很快感到失望。那是一封非常无聊的信。他确实以一种非常详尽和技术性的方式回答了我的问题。
Quote, "The earliest reference to Higgs Bosons that I know is in the late Ben Lee's talk as rapporteur at the 1972 Rochester conference at Fermilab," end quote. It was filled with stuff like this, names and dates. Quote, "It is possible, however, that the terminology was being used before the 1972 conference following 't Hooft's rediscovery of the Anderson, Brout, Englert, Higgs et al. mechanism the previous year."
引用：“我所知的关于希格斯玻色子的最早参考资料是已故本·李在1972年费米实验室罗彻斯特会议上作为报告人的讲话。”引用结束。里面全是这类东西，人名和日期。引用：“然而，有可能在1972年会议之前，随着特霍夫特在前一年重新发现安德森、布鲁特、恩格勒、希格斯等人的机制，这个术语就已经在使用中了。”
It was the kind of frustrating experience that I was having with a lot of scientists. They gave you tons of detail that no one else would care about or could possibly remember. And as to my request to talk on the phone for a few minutes, which is my real hope, nothing. I pinned the letter up in my cubicle with a thumbtack, then, after a while, moved it to a drawer. 14 years went by.
这和我与许多科学家的经历一样令人沮丧。他们给你提供大量别人根本不在意或者根本记不住的细节。至于我请求谈几分钟电话的真实希望，什么都没有。我用图钉把那封信钉在我的隔间里，过了一阵子，就把它移到了抽屉里。14年过去了。
In 2012, nearly 50 years after Higgs wrote that this particle might exist, we learned it really did, just as he had said it might. Giant teams of physicists managed to make and detect some Higgs particles at the CERN laboratory in Europe. It was a massive multibillion dollar effort. Peter Higgs won the Nobel Prize for it the following year.
2012年，在希格斯写下这种粒子可能存在的近50年后，我们得知它确实存在，正如他所说的那样。庞大的物理学家团队成功在欧洲CERN实验室制造并探测到了一些希格斯粒子。这是一项价值数十亿美元的巨大努力。彼得·希格斯在次年因此获得了诺贝尔奖。
The letter still sat in a drawer at my house. I got married, had kids. Last year, I came across the letter again, finally stuck it in a frame. Should I say where it is? It's in the bathroom. And then, a few months ago, Peter Higgs died. He was 94 years old.
那封信依然躺在我家里的抽屉里。我结婚了，有了孩子。去年，我又偶然发现了这封信，终于把它装进了相框。我该说它在哪儿吗？它在浴室里。然后，几个月前，彼得·希格斯去世了。他享年94岁。
I went back and read the letter again, really for the first time since I'd gotten it almost 25 years ago. And I got very emotional reading it. There's something in there that the younger me had been unable to see or appreciate. What Peter Higgs was doing in this letter was going out of his way to try to give credit to everyone else.
我回去又读了一遍那封信，这几乎是我自25年前收到它以来的第一次阅读。读的时候我感触良多。那里面有什么是年轻的我未能看到或欣赏的。彼得·希格斯在那封信里所做的是，他不遗余力地尝试将功劳归于其他人。
Some scientists spend their lives angling for a Nobel Prize. Higgs was trying to downplay his role in everything, to put it in its proper context. It was generous and humble. He'd taken the time to write it all carefully out and send it to a reporter across the ocean that he'd never met.
有些科学家一生都在为诺贝尔奖钻营。希格斯却试图淡化他在一切事情中的角色，将它放在应有的语境中。这是慷慨而谦逊的。他花了时间将其仔细写出，并寄给了一位从未谋面的远在大洋彼岸的记者。
I went online and found a recording of Higgs talking at a press conference after he won the Nobel. Actually, he shared the prize with another guy. In the press conference, he's doing the same thing he was in that letter.
我上网找到了希格斯在获得诺贝尔奖后举行的新闻发布会上发言的录音。其实他与另一位学者共同分享了奖项。在新闻发布会上，他所做的正是他在那封信里做的事。
A lot of people seem to think that I did all this single-handed. It was actually part of a theoretical program, which had been started in 1960. The man who really initiated it was Yuri Kiro Nabu, originally from Japan, who is now back in Japan. So it's part of a story which goes back at least to 1960. And 1964 was just what turned out to be a rather successful episode in that story.
许多人似乎认为我是独立完成这一切的。这实际上是一个理论项目的一部分，该项目始于1960年。真正发起它的人是最初来自日本、现在又回到日本的南部阳一郎。所以这是可以追溯到至少1960年的故事的一部分。而1964年只是那个故事中一个相当成功的插曲。
In the press conference, Higgs also mentions this thing I never knew, which is that he only wrote about the particle in the first place sort of by chance. His first draft of his now famous paper was actually rejected by the journal he tried to publish it in. So he went back and basically added a few lines, mentioning that if all the other stuff was true, there might be a new particle also, one people could find someday.
在新闻发布会上，希格斯还提到了我从未知道的一件事，那就是他最初写那个粒子完全是偶然的。他现在著名的论文初稿实际上被他试图投稿的期刊拒绝了。所以他回去后基本增加了几行，提到如果其他内容属实，也可能存在一种新的粒子，一种人们将来某天可能会找到的粒子。
Higgs wasn't the only one who could have done what he did, but what he did was remarkable. And at the end of the day, he was the one who got to carry the baton over the finish line. When I look back at the letter now, I think, seems like a nice guy for that to happen to. I'm glad it was him.
并不是只有希格斯能做到他所做的事，但他所做的确实非凡。到最后，他成了那个带着接力棒跨过终点线的人。现在回顾那封信，我想，他确实是个好人，值得这一切。我很庆幸那个人是他。
David Kestenbaum is senior editor of our show. Coming up, somebody has an urgent and deeply personal request for the US Army, also other letters. That's in a minute. Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
大卫·克里斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的资深编辑。接下来，有人向美国陆军提出了一个紧急且非常个人的请求，还有其他信件。稍后回来。在节目继续时，欢迎收听芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Letters, Actual Letters, in which we hear the vast variety of things that can happen when you put your thoughts and feelings down on paper. We've arrived at Act Four of our program. Act Four, "Dear US Army."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“信件，真实的信件”，我们要听到当人们把自己的思想和感受写在纸上时会发生的各种各样的事情。我们来到了节目的第四幕。第四幕，“亲爱的美国陆军”。
So a letter doesn't have to be long to get its point across. This one, read by the actor Crystal Clarke at the Royal Albert Hall in London for Letters Live, does its job with admirable efficiency.
所以，一封信不一定要很长才能表达清楚意思。这封由演员克里斯蒂尔·克拉克在伦敦皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅为“书信现场”朗读的信件，以令人赞叹的效率完成了任务。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
November 1943, Draft Board, Poinsett County, Arkansas. Dear United States Army, my husband asked me to write a recommendation telling you that he supports his family. He cannot read, so don't tell him.
1943年11月，征兵委员会，波因塞特县，阿肯色州。亲爱的美国陆军，我丈夫让我写封推荐信，告诉你们他会赡养家人。他不识字，所以别告诉他。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He ain't no good to me.
他对我一点用都没有。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He ain't done nothing but raise hell and drink lemon essence since I married him eight years ago. And I got to feed seven kids of his. Maybe you can get him to carry a gun. He's good with squirrels and eating. Take him and welcome. I need the grub and his bed for the kids. Don't tell him this, but just take him and send him as far as you can.
自从八年前我嫁给他以来，他除了闹事和喝柠檬精，什么都没做过。我得养活他那七个孩子。也许你们能让他扛枪。他很擅长捉松鼠和吃东西。带走他吧，欢迎你们带走。我需要吃的，还需要他的床位给孩子们用。别告诉他这些，只管带走他，把他送到尽可能远的地方去。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Mrs. Cassy Murdoch.
卡西·默多克夫人。
Crystal Clarke reading a letter for Letters Live.
克里斯蒂尔·克拉克为“书信现场”朗读的信件。
Act Five, "Dear Zoe." There are the letters you get, and then there are the letters you wish you got. And the gap between those two things can say so much. Here's producer Zoe Chace.
第五幕，“亲爱的佐伊”。有你收到的信，还有你希望收到的信。这两者之间的差距可以说明很多事情。下面是制作人佐伊·切斯。
My dad wrote a lot of letters. He wrote them to me and to everyone in his life. After my parents got divorced, he would write to me at my mom's house, even though I'd see him that weekend. He'd send postcards that just said, for instance, "Punch buggy blue, no punch back." It was 1989. I was eight years old. He was almost 60.
我爸爸写了很多信。他写给我，也写给他生活中的每个人。我父母离婚后，他会写信给我妈家，尽管周末我都会见到他。他会寄明信片，上面只写着，比如，“蓝色打孔车，不能打回来。”那是1989年。我八岁。他快60岁了。
He treated letters sometimes like text messages because he wrote so many for big and small reasons, sometimes two a week, sending an inside joke between us, or always, he'd send along his plans.
他有时对待信件就像对待短信一样，因为他写得太多，原因有大有小，有时一周两封，发送我们之间的小笑话，或者总是顺便寄来他的计划。
"Here are the plans. Come with me for the weekend after you get back. You can come to my office on Friday. And then we have dinner with Silvana. We might also see a movie called El Cid, about a famous warrior in the Middle Ages in Spain. I have to bring you home on Sunday of that week about noon-ish, because I have to teach, even though there's a holiday on Monday-- Labor Day."
“计划如下。你回来后的周末跟我一起。周五你可以来我的办公室。然后我们和西尔瓦娜一起吃晚餐。我们可能还会看一部叫《熙德》的电影，关于中世纪西班牙的一位著名战士。那周周日中午左右我得把你送回家，因为我得去教书，尽管周一是假期——劳动节。”
Semicolon, "At this point, we can go to the harbor the following weekend. I pick you up at school, and off we go." That was August 1993. He'd often add, in a PS, "I am writing to you without using capital letters because I like to write letters that way, because it is time consuming and boring to make caps. You should not do this because it is a bad habit until you are grown-up."
分号，“到时候，我们可以去港口，就在下个周末。我去学校接你，然后我们就出发。”那是1993年8月。他经常在附言中加上：“我写信时不使用大写字母，因为我喜欢那样写信，因为使用大写字母太耗时又无聊。你不应该这样做，因为在你成年之前这是一种坏习惯。”
As I grew up, the letters grew up. They took on a different tone. Here's one from May 20, 1995. "Dear Zoe, this is another letter from Dad. All of those can be kept over the years and then reread and then used in your memoirs." This is the tone-- grandiose. He's offering important words of guidance to his child.
随着我长大，信件也成熟了。它们有了不同的语气。这是一封1995年5月20日的信：“亲爱的佐伊，这是爸爸的另一封信。所有这些都可以留着，多年后重读，然后写进你的回忆录里。”这就是这种语气——宏大。他在给孩子提供重要的指导性语言。
It goes on. "It is important to understand the nature of work and how it will affect your life, whether school work or something else. What you will find out in most work situations is the way in which work helps one to get through hard times. I know that when I split up with both Jean and your mother, it helped me to have a job, to give me structure, so that I could survive OK and look forward to a better time when things would be better for me.
信中写道：“理解工作的本质以及它将如何影响你的生活是很重要的，无论是学业还是其他事情。在大多数工作场合，你会发现工作有助于人度过难关。我知道当我与简和你妈妈分手时，有一份工作、有结构让我能够生存下去，并期待未来事情会变得更好，这对我很有帮助。”
So work helps a lot in that respect. If you have ups and downs at school and social matters, for example, well, the work, schoolwork, but also in your case, sports, helps to get one through a rough period. I don't mean that work, whether it be sports, which you take seriously and should, replaces human values-- friends, lovers, whatever. But it helps complete the roundness of life. Believe me." I was in sixth grade. "PS, don't use lowercase when you type. That's just for me. Otherwise, you will get into bad habits."
“所以工作在这方面帮助很大。比如你在学校和社交上有起伏，嗯，工作，学业，但在你的案例中还有运动，能帮助你度过困难时期。我并不是说工作，无论是运动——你对待它很认真，也应该这样——会取代人类的价值观——朋友、爱人，无论是什么。但它有助于完成生活的圆满。相信我。”我在上六年级。“附言，打字时别用小写。那只是针对我的。否则，你会养成坏习惯的。”
Dad was a writer, a historian, magazine editor, professor, foreign policy guy. A dry subject, maybe, but he was not a dry person. He was warm and loving and excited. And so were his letters. What they weren't really was vulnerable. They weren't peer to peer. They were father to daughter, which I loved. I didn't want it to be different. I liked being taken care of and guided and mentored and fussed over. And he was just clearly enjoying playing the role he was playing.
爸爸是作家、历史学家、杂志编辑、教授、外交政策专家。主题可能枯燥，但他不是一个枯燥的人。他热情、充满爱心且兴奋。他的信件也是如此。但它们实际上并非坦诚。它们不是平辈之间的对话，而是父女之间，我很喜欢。我不希望有什么不同。我喜欢被照顾、被指导、被辅导和被呵护。他显然很享受扮演自己的那个角色。
June 30, 1999. I was 17, 12th grade. "Dear Zoe, the opening lines of The Divine Comedy-- 'In the middle of the road of our life, I found myself in a dark wood where the straight way was hidden.' In any case, sometimes one does find oneself in a dark wood, and the right way, the straight, is lost. And one has to find the path again and sometimes again and again. How is camp?"
1999年6月30日。我17岁，高三。“亲爱的佐伊，《神曲》的开头行——‘在人生的中途，我发现自己置身于一片幽暗的森林中，直路消失了。’无论如何，有时人们确实会发现自己处于一片幽暗的森林中，正确的道路，那条笔直的路，丢失了。一个人必须再次找到路径，有时是一次又一次。营地怎么样？”
The last missive I received from Dad came two days after he died in 2004. It was a postcard he'd mailed from Paris. I can't find it now, but I remember he recommended against opening a credit card. Just stick with a debit card for now. I was 22. I didn't get another letter from him, until this year, in June.
我收到爸爸的最后一封信是在他2004年去世两天后。那是一张他从巴黎寄来的明信片。我现在找不到了，但我记得他建议不要开信用卡。先用借记卡就好。我22岁。直到今年六月，我才再次收到他的信。
As his friends have died, their families found these old letters my dad had written to them and sent the letters to my sisters and me. I got one from Dad from 1960. He was 28 years old. I was 42, reading it. It was the first letter I'd ever read where he was younger than me and the first where he was writing to another adult.
随着他的朋友们相继去世，他们的家人发现了这些我爸爸以前写给他们的旧信，并将信寄给了我和我的姐妹们。我收到了一封爸爸1960年的信。他28岁。我42岁，正在阅读。这是我读过的第一封他比我年轻的信，也是第一封他写给另一个成年人的信。
It was very different from the ones I used to get-- no lessons or grand gestures or guidance. It was about his first book, which was a novel. He wrote it in his 20s while living in Paris, serving in the army. Looking through the book, it was clear Hemingway was very much on his mind. It was called The Rules of the Game, A Novel of Love and Folly. It was published in 1960. It was not received well, I gather. The letter was to his brother-in-law at the time, Jack.
它和我以前收到的非常不同——没有教训、宏大的手势或指导。它是关于他的第一本书，那是一部小说。他在20多岁时在巴黎服兵役期间写了它。读过那本书后，很显然海明威一直在他脑海里。书名叫《游戏规则：一部关于爱与疯狂的小说》。它出版于1960年。我推测它反响并不好。这封信是写给他当时的姐夫杰克的。
"Dear, Jack, thank you so much for your letter about the book. It was so good to have someone discuss the book in terms of its moral implications, rather than stylistic or technical fault. The fact is, of course, that I am only too aware of its shortcomings, or, indeed, more aware than ever before.
“亲爱的杰克，非常感谢你关于这本书的信。有人能从道德内涵而非文体或技术缺陷的角度讨论这本书，真是太好了。事实当然是，我对自己作品的缺点知之甚多，甚至比以往任何时候都清楚。”
To counterweight my own despair about this, I'm working harder than ever on my next book, which I hope will be richer and fuller than The Rules. At the moment, I am enveloped by critical silence-- a hard lesson, but maybe a good one. A tough outer skin is something I need. I'm learning to grow one."
“为了平衡我对此的绝望，我正在比以往任何时候都更加努力地投入下一本书，我希望它能比《规则》更丰富、更饱满。此刻，我被批评的沉默所笼罩——一个艰难的教训，但也可能是一个好教训。我需要厚厚的外皮。我正在学习长出一层。”
He never wrote to me about his insecurities. In my 20s and 30s, I would have loved to know that he had this feeling, to hear him talk about the weight of being a newish adult so disappointed with yourself after imagining greatness and trying really hard and seeing the lack of greatness.
他从没写信告诉我他的不安。在我的20多岁和30多岁时，我会非常想知道他有过这种感觉，听到他谈论作为一个初出茅庐的成年人，在想象伟大之后却对自己如此失望、付出巨大努力却看到缺乏成就时的重压。
Even at 42, it was a comfort to see him questioning everything he was doing. That kind of self-doubt and self-criticism is a huge part of my personality. That is every day. And apparently, it was a thing we had in common, my dad and me. I didn't know.
即使在42岁时，看着他质疑自己所做的一切也是一种安慰。那种自我怀疑和自我批评是我人格中巨大的组成部分。那是每天的日常。显然，这也是我和我爸爸共同拥有的东西。我以前不知道。
I got a letter he wrote to someone else, a close family friend known to me as Aunt Maggie. It was 1966. He was in his 30s. He was dating someone new, before my mom. "Dear Maggie, the novel proceeds apace, and my agent is happy with it. Finally, I have met a woman who I am very fond of. We have been going out-- is that the word-- since the end of October, and it is very nice, indeed, to have someone who cares a lot about one. Dare I use the word "love"?
我得到了一封他写给别人的信，一位我称之为玛吉姨妈的密友。那是1966年。他30多岁。他正在和一个新的人约会，在我妈妈之前。“亲爱的玛吉，小说进展顺利，我的经纪人很满意。终于，我遇到了一个我非常喜欢的人。我们一直在约会——是这个词吗——从十月底开始，有一个关心自己的人真是太好了。我敢使用‘爱’这个词吗？”
Life seems to me so insubstantial, so filled with eggshells that I will predict nothing. But she makes me happy. And she is very kind, straight, and quite remarkably beautiful. Also, she is 33 and has not been married. Her hang-ups, whatever they are, strike me as minor. She is so loving and giving. Enfin, who knows? Maybe my luck is changing. And then again, you see the old distrust for happiness."
“生活对我来说如此虚无，充满了鸡蛋壳，我什么都不敢预测。但她让我快乐。她非常善良、直率，而且相当美丽。此外，她33岁，还没结过婚。她的那些心结，无论是什么，在我看来都很轻微。她如此充满爱和给予。终于，谁知道呢？也许我的运气在好转。又或者，你又看到了我对幸福的旧时怀疑。”
He had that, too? The feeling that things would always go wrong? That even if it feels good in the moment, it's a trick. It won't last. I didn't know. There's another letter to Maggie in which every single feeling in it is new to me, not to my experience, of course-- frustration, heartbreak, hopelessness-- just new to my experience of my dad. He was in the middle of his first messy divorce. He had two young kids, my sisters.
他也有那种感觉吗？那种事情总会出错的感觉？那种即使当下感觉良好，也是个圈套的感觉。它不会持久。我不知道。还有另一封写给玛吉的信，里面的每一个感受对我来说都是新鲜的，当然不是指我的经历——挫折、心碎、绝望——只是对于我爸爸的经历来说是新鲜的。他正处于第一次混乱的离婚中。他有两个年幼的孩子，我的姐妹。
"Dear Maggie, a mad Chace letter because I can't really call up, and sometimes it is good to get things down on paper. No reply called for. I have realized you can't just move out when things get too hot. No one's life is that bloody good anyway. No one has it knocked.
“亲爱的玛吉，一封疯狂的切斯信，因为我真的打不了电话，而且有时把事情写在纸上会好些。无需回信。我意识到，当事情变得太棘手时，你不能直接搬走。反正没人的生活有那么好。没谁能搞定这一切。”
Yet I do not look forward to the future. I see breakdown and trouble and pain. And no matter how one tries, one cannot be indifferent. Take care of yourself. I'll be leaving June 6 and back June 27. Hang on by your thumbs."
“但我并不期待未来。我看到了崩溃、麻烦和痛苦。无论一个人怎么努力，都无法漠不关心。保重。我将在6月6日离开，6月27日回来。咬牙坚持住。”
A parent keeping their hard-earned bitterness from you is a gift. It's generosity, not selfishness. I'm grateful for that. Still, I remember our last conversation. We were at a bar in Fall River, Massachusetts, the old mill town where my dad grew up. The TVs were on-- the Olympics, I think-- people striving to perfect perfection in the background.
一个父母把自己辛苦得来的苦涩对你隐瞒，是一种馈赠。那是慷慨，而非自私。我为此感到感激。不过，我记得我们的最后一次对话。我们在马萨诸塞州福尔河的一家酒吧，那是爸爸成长的小磨坊镇。电视开着——我想是奥运会——人们在背景中努力追求完美。
I was talking to Dad about my new job, first post-college job, how cool the people were who worked there, how afraid I was they wouldn't like me. "That's the old Zoe," Dad said. "You don't need to spend time worrying what people think about you anymore." OK. I looked away and didn't say anything. I wasn't looking for advice at that moment.
我正跟爸爸谈论我的新工作，大学毕业后的第一份工作，谈论那些同事有多酷，我有多害怕他们不喜欢我。“那是旧佐伊，”爸爸说。“你不需要再花时间去担心别人怎么想你了。”好吧。我移开目光，什么也没说。我当时并不是在寻求建议。
Maybe if I'd known this was the last conversation we were ever going to have, I would have asked a question. Have you ever felt this way? Tell me about it. Tell me everything about that. I wish he'd told me more about second guessing himself, about errors and uncertainty.
也许如果我知道这是我们最后一次对话，我会问一个问题。你曾经有这种感觉吗？告诉我关于它的事。把那一切都告诉我。我希望他能多告诉我一些关于自我怀疑的事，关于错误和不确定性。
But really, there's not any specific thing I wish he'd told me. It's not that I always wanted to know, am I like you? Are you like me? Are we the same? It's that we were interrupted when he died. That's what I hate. I wanted our conversations to continue and to change and expand.
但真的，并没有什么特别的事情我希望他告诉我。并不是说我一直想知道，我像你吗？你像我吗？我们是一样的吗？是我们在他去世时被打断了。那是我最恨的。我希望我们的对话能继续下去，并改变和扩展。
The letters are great. I love the letters. The letters are what I have. But the letters are fixed. They leave me sur ma faim, as Dad might say-- still hungry. They end, "Endless love, Dad." It's not the same as having a conversation. It's nothing like what a conversation would be.
这些信件很好。我喜欢这些信。这些信是我拥有的东西。但信件是固定的。正如爸爸可能会说的，它们让我“sur ma faim”（依然感到饥饿）。它们以“无尽的爱，爸爸”结尾。这和谈话是不一样的。它根本不像谈话会有的样子。
Zoe Chace is a producer on our show.
佐伊·切斯是我们节目的制作人。
["SOME POSTMAN" BY THE PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA]
["Some Postman" by The Presidents of the United States of America]
Our program was produced today by Bim Adewunmi and edited by our executive editor Emanuele Berry. The people put together today's show include Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Joffe-Walt, Henry Larson, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alix Spiegel, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目由比姆·阿德温米制作，并由我们的执行编辑伊曼纽尔·贝里编辑。今天参与节目制作的人包括詹达伊·邦兹、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、亨利·拉尔森、托宾·洛、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞恩·鲁梅里、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Special thanks today to Rebecca Chace, Sarah Chace, Susan Chace, Frank Close, and Victoria Martin. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream over 800 episodes of our show for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to local public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. His new get rich quick scheme? He lights incense, sets a dollar bill on fire, and slowly chants--
我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。特别感谢今天的丽贝卡·切斯、莎拉·切斯、苏珊·切斯、弗兰克·克洛斯和维多利亚·马丁。我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，您可以免费收听我们节目800多集的音频。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX负责发送给当地公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他新的快速致富计划？他点上香，把一张美元钞票烧掉，然后缓慢地吟唱——
Financial, financial, secret to wealth.
金融、金融、财富秘诀。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给您更多《美国生活》的故事。
["SOME POSTMAN" BY THE PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA"]
["Some Postman" by The Presidents of the United States of America]